[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's going crazy
hey guys we're finally here gordon's bay
south africa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and tomorrow morning early we'll go deep
into the ocean
and fight giant tuna to see who will win
the deep sea
fishing competition
and the prize is this trophy over here
and the hamper over here and the
contestants are
myself and then we got donny aka
beast
and then we got ornay aka mu
okay ah and then we got jaw aka
smiling
and then lastly we got clifton
mr grumpy
and finally our judge and skipper
patrick
aka mcmaster so yeah let's get it done
[Music]
[Music]
yo look at all these dolphins
so
you can't beat this mother nature
we're here the competition is about to
start patrick
you're the referee what are the rules
hey guys morning to you
um what we're gonna do this morning is
we're gonna the first kind of fishing
we're gonna do we're gonna put some
backgrounds out here
and we're gonna do what we call trolling
so we're gonna try and get yellowfins up
we don't know where the tuna at the
moment we're gonna do a bit of a probe
so we can see exactly where they are and
we're gonna cover some ground with some
lures out the back
what we're going to do is a rotational
system so
we're going to have every rod allocated
to a person's name
and are you happy with 20 minutes we'll
do a 20 minute rotation then everybody
will just move up like a musical chair
so
we'll start from left to right work from
port to starboard around
and um whoever's on that rod that goes
at the exact time
he's lucky he's in the pound seats to to
try and get on the board with the
biggest fish
as the competition is the biggest fish
for the day am i right right
perfect let's do it
[Applause]
we didn't get anything yet we're going
to change tactics right patrick
absolutely
so what we're going to do now guys is
we're well we've stopped now we've
pulled the back lines in
and we're gonna revert to good old bait
um i'm gonna be cutting some
chamia which we call a smarty trail and
see if we can get a fish up from the
deep to come up on the bait
and then we'll be baiting with two rods
so the competition now
is going from the rod competitioner to
the actual
ching chong cha competition and we'll
put baits in the water see if we can get
a few fish up
and then it's up to the guys to fast
draw on the ching tong chat to see who
takes the rod first
so yeah let's get it done
[Music]
it's on
[Music]
just like ah
guys the competition is one
one one one
[Music]
this guy's so heavy so strong i can't
even bring him in
good so far we got a fish in 40 kilos
let's see it's gonna stay the biggest
fish let's see
time will tell
[Music]
come on look at his face distressing so
much
double hook up here we go
but exhausting
go around
doubling up
[Music]
this is awesome
double action yep
easy grumpy
it's not going to be bigger at 40 kilos
huh or is it
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
mute is ready he's being strapped in
beast is dropping him in
so he's ready for the next round
[Music]
nice
[Music]
yes
[Music]
high five dude
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and we're good to go
[Music]
all right guys we're done with the
competition patrick here is gonna
tell us who is the winner we're gonna
start first with the fish that is
the smallest of you thank you very much
okay guys after a wonderful day at sea
together i hope you guys all enjoyed
that
um because i seriously did okay guys so
in fifth place
we have ornay with a fish
of eighteen point two kilos
in fourth place we've got jock with a
fish of nineteen point three kilos
next as well good man
then in third place we have
donny point four killer
four getting there like a forty forty
two pounder
nothing wrong
great job thanks guys and
in second place
well the fish are 46.5 kilograms what
oh that's big so that's a very good
yellow flower
it's clifton
so that means that that means
the man of the hour is dead
take first place thank you thank you
with a fish that does over 100 pounds
of 52.5 kilograms
54.8 kilos
so i'll keep it until the next the next
match
but it's mine for now and this guy
hold on thank you guys very well
thank you thanks thank you
should we eat those steaks absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]